hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
treffen will
heute möchte ich euch zeigen wie ich
meine spätzle hersteller und zwar ist es
ein grundrezept ich habe das jetzt
ausgelegt auf zwei bis drei personen
wenn ich die spätzle als hauptspeise
serviert dann ist es für zwei personen
gedacht und wenn ich es eher als beilage
serviert dann für drei personen
die spätzle könnt ihr verfeinern ich
hatte diese ja schon mal bei der tochter
tegan gemacht und hab da mango und mit
eingearbeitet heute weil sich die
variante mit spinat machen weil ich es
eigentlich mit spinat lieber mag und das
immer so gemacht habe bisher ihr könnt
dieses schwätzle rezept wie gesagt ganz
einfach lassen oder eben etwas gemüse
mit einarbeiten den spinat oder den mann
kommt könnt ihr frisch verwenden also
etwas in der salzwasser blanchieren
abschrecken und dann pürieren
oder ihr nehmt einfach tiefkühl spinat
so mache ich das jetzt heute weil das
viel einfacher installieren tiefkühl
spinat einfach noch die ganzen vitamine
enthalten sind weil der direkt nach der
ernte eben schockgefrostet wird jetzt
zeige ich euch einfach mal die zutaten
und zeigt euch wie es weitergeht
das hier ist jetzt die grundzutaten ich
habe drei eier 300 gramm mehr
etwa 150 milliliter wasser salz und
guten teelöffel das darf schon ein
bisschen mehr sein
pfeffer und frische mit karte
die habe ich jetzt da einfach so weg
gegeben je nach geschmack und ihr könnt
pro person etwa ein ei rechnen und pro
ei benutzt man dann eben 100 gramm mehl
und 50 gramm wasser und man benutzt
immer etwas meersalz weil der teig dann
eben etwas salziger wird und dann noch
etwas von dem kochenden wasser mit in
sich aufnimmt und so werden die spätzle
oder die knöpfle eben viel leichter wird
erst jetzt tiefgekühlter spinat den ich
jetzt aufgetaucht
da habe ich jetzt so 220 gramm ich
möchte ich aber mal zeigen wie viel
flüssigkeit in so tiefe vorn in sachen
ist da veräppelt uns die industrie
nämlich ganz schön geben dann nämlich
ziemlich viel wasser rein
also hier könnte mal sehen so sieht mein
ausgedrückter spinat aus und da hat
immer noch viel flüssigkeit in sich und
ich habe hier 115 gramm flüssigkeit raus
gedrückt und das waren ursprünglich 220
gramm das heißt die hälfte davon ist
flüssigkeit ich hatte damals nämlich so
ein beitrag gesehen und haben gesehen
dass die kraft bei tiefkühlprodukten
viel wasser mit einarbeiten weil das
eben was wiegt und dabei eben weniger
produkt in der tüte so ich kleider
jetzt kommen einfach alle zutaten hier
rein früher hat man das so gemacht dass
man den teig mit einem kochlöffel
verrührt hat den hut war es sozusagen
geschlagen rasen geworfen hat aber ich
werde diese zeit mit meinem android
gerät machen weil es einfach schneller
geht
da kommt jetzt noch salz und muskatnuss
und dann gebe ich jetzt mal dritteln
fertig vom wasser das man übrig und
verrät es erstmal
[Musik]
wenn ihr dann so einen schönen
zähflüssigen karten gehabt ist teig
fertig also das weiß praktisch das
konzept für ganz normale spätzle und
hier gebe ich wie gesagt jetzt noch
meine spieler betreiben den teig denke
ich jetzt ganz locker mit einem feuchten
tuch ab und lassen den einfach kurz ein
bisschen applaus ruhen bis ich eben den
rest vorbereitet habe und bis das wasser
auch wer eine kitchenette hat oder eine
andere küchenmaschine kann den teig auch
ganz einfach in der maschine machen
ich wollte es euch einfach mal zeigen
wie es auch ohne küchenmaschine geht
weil die meisten ja noch keine
küchenmaschine haben und zwar nehmt ihr
dann dazu diesen flach hörer schmeißt
dann andere zutaten in der mixed ob und
berührt das ganze bei höchster stufe so
etwa eine minute bis der teig geben die
richtige konsistenz hat den teig muss da
jetzt ein bisschen ruhen lassen und in
dieser zeit weil ich schon mal die
röstzwiebeln vorbereiten damit die
ebenfalls gleich fertig werden
ich nehme so etwa zwei bis drei zwiebeln
und werde diese scheele und die müssen
dort in feine ringe oder halb ringe
geschnitten werden und für mich ist hier
das schnellste und effektivste methode
die mit dem vogel
da habe ich mal der titel aber schon
frauen schneiden ohne mir dabei in die
hände zu schneiden und so mache ich das
mit dem restlichen auf und gibt sie dann
in eine schüssel und dann gebe ich hier
noch etwa zwei esslöffel mehl mit rein
und schwenkt zwiebel schön so dass der
komplett mit mehl und man sitzt in einer
pfanne habe ich jetzt etwa zwei
esslöffel butter und gibt da noch einen
schuss öl betreiben
einfach damit die butter jetzt nicht
anbrennen und das lasse ich einmal so
zergehen
und sobald die mutter und das öl schön
warm geworden sind gebe ich da die
zwiebeln mit rein und lassen sie bei
mittlerer stufe etwas möchte ich habe
mir hier einen topf mit einem seil zu
recht gestellt
da kann ich ja ich die spätzle rein
schöpfen und meine knöpfle jetzt hier in
kochendem salzwasser kochen
dazu benutze ich das gerät vom typ
erfahren ich habe zwar auch eine
spezielle presse aber nicht funktioniert
netze rot und ich bevor ich das jetzt
vorher einmal damit gehe damit der teig
bleibt dran
dann kommt ein bisschen vorteil kein
nicht zu viel
und dann wird es hier einfach drüber
geschafft
und sobald sie oben schwimmen ich war
jetzt auch möglich das wasser richtig
heiß wird können das ja dann raus
fischer das geht sehen wie schnell
sie wollen immer mal wieder schwenken
das war als meine letzte fraktion ich
habe insgesamt drei quartieren gemacht
das heißt pro person könnte immer eine
portion nach eingeben
das heißt wenn ihr fünf fraktionen macht
musst du eben den vorgang fünf mal
machen zu sehen eine rast rebellen jetzt
aus selb auch schön kross
jetzt würde ich dann noch etwas salz mit
rein geben weil die zwiebeln jetzt etwas
süßlich schmecken
ich weiss ich ganz gern mag aber so
haben sie eben keine würze und hier seht
ihr die zwiebeln sind richtig schön
kross und werden dann nach dem abkühlen
richtig schön knusprig eine spezialistin
jetzt fertig und könnte theoretisch auch
verschiedene soßen dazu machen oder sie
mit etwa mit einer hauptspeise servieren
aber ich werde sie heute einfach in
etwas butter schwenken die butter weil
ich etwas frauen werden lassen damit sie
ein nussiges aroma bekommt und wie ich
das mache zeige ich euch jetzt
jetzt mache ich erstmal nur eine kleine
menge weil mein mann grad noch nicht da
ist das heißt ich muss jetzt erst mal
alleine essen
ich gebe jetzt etwas butter in einer
pfanne die panne war richtig schön
dann gebe ich da jetzt einfach ein
bisschen
[Musik]
dann gebe ich dir da einfach so auf
meinen teller dann kommen hier noch ein
paar aus zwiebeln drauf und fertig sind
meine spinat knöpfler mit röstzwiebeln
und die restlichen glück liebe war ich
hier einfach auf bis man eben kommt und
falls die dann später nicht so schnell
auseinander gehen also wenn sie zusammen
kleben könnte auch ein bisschen von
dieser flüssigkeit darüber geben die
eben also von dieser koch flüssigkeit
dann lösen sie sich ganz schnell und
dann können dass sie in butter geben
etwas streng schwenken und fertig ich
hoffe dieses rezept gefällt euch denn
ihr probiert mal aus wie gesagt könnt
ihr dieses grundrezept sehr variieren
ihr könnt auch süße spätzle draus machen
dass man sich auch ganz lecker die habe
ich mal mit honig und mit etwas klappt
serviert kann ich euch vielleicht auch
mahlzeiten und jetzt wünsche ich euch
viel spaß beim nachmachen das rezept
könnt ihr wie immer nachlesen auf meinem
blog bei schrotten welt.de
wenn euch das video gefallen hat würde
ich mich freuen wenn ihr es mit euren
freunden teilt und mir eine bewertung
gibt und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder mit einem neuen
rezept und ja dann bis bald
[Musik]